will you there yo can you hear me yeah
we can hear you man how are you
good good good how you guys doing we're
doing fantastic well here we go some
aggressive bitcoin buying on coinbase
what's going on
yeah so
this is this is a
trading light which is one of like my
favorite platforms and just so like
people know what's going on price action
like in the last like 10 minutes so on
the top is obviously price and then
those little like scattered lines that
you can ignore that those are like the
active bids and asks on coinbase right
now but what you'll see in the middle is
that's the volume so there's those green
bars showing there's really high volume
and then at the bottom you see that the
green line that's cbd which is
cumulative volume delta it's showing you
is the price um you know the active
market price moving more towards the bid
or the ask so it's basically showing you
our buyers or sellers more aggressive in
the market um and so you know that in
combination with volume is basically
showing you there's an aggressive buyer
on coinbase right now so that's that's
just what's going on in like the
immediate term and so that's what's
driving kind of this quick price
increase is that there's some major
buyer on coinbase scooping up bitcoin
yeah oh yeah we call it t-whopping where
they're basically you know like
averaging in um you know a large buy
right you can't just fat thumb a large
buy
which by the way i mean speaking of fat
thumbing that price action yesterday was
pretty funny where we had someone
basically just like
market selling this really fat or
liquidated like 46 million there's 47
million dollars of longs and then we
just continued right up it's a complete
scam price action it's been uh it's been
it's been some weird some weird pa over
the last two days yesterday like i said
we had that big seller and now looks
like we have some aggressive buying on
coinbase but yeah for listeners like
trading light is awesome you can go in
and look at per exchange uh basically
like this heat map of all the bids and
asks and then overlay some of these
other indicators but anyway we can get
into the newsletter i just wanted to to
i love that one on wait a second
okay let's start with the future
perpetual funding rate what exactly is
this and what's it telling us
right so the funding rate is based on
the delta between
the spot price and um in the market
price which is you know different on
each exchange so you're looking at the
weighted average of all the uh spot
exchanges versus what the actual
perpetual swap contract price is trading
on
and so this what you're looking at is
the aggregated uh version of this but
what you want to look for with funding
is um
not necessarily the fact i think there's
this misconception that when you have
positive funding that it's that it's
always bearish and that's not the case
because
it can just be the the price of doing
business at the time right if if the
market's trending bullish then that's
just the cost of doing business in a in
a bullish market and you know contrarily
you know if if you're in you know
bearish market there's kind of the cost
of doing business or if you have a large
liquidation cascade that can drive the
perp contract lower than spot
and you can have negative funding where
i think funding is really a good tool is
when you have these dislocations between
the trend of it and price
and so really good example of this was
right after we broke all-time highs that
really big uh little cluster that you
see on the left-hand side that's uh
funding mooning up to like 150 apr and
some exchanges um which is you know
obviously a bit concerning in itself but
where you really would would be
concerned um was and that's that second
kind of spike on the right hand of right
hand side of that first cluster and the
reason is because price is grinding down
while funding is rising and so
essentially what that's saying is the
force that the perpetual swap you know
traders are exerting so they're they're
leveraged longing as price is going down
so they're basically you know getting
faded by what the spot market is doing
and that's that's a huge red flag
and so if you remember a long time ago
like at the end of summer we called this
big short squeeze off the lows and this
is the complete opposite set up
price was rising funding was going the
opposite and so
using these dislocations can give some
good signal about what happens in in the
market
and over the last couple days on
wednesday i think it was wednesday night
um you had this another dislocation
where price was grinding down funding
was rising and that was a big big red
flag um you also had open interest uh
spiking and particularly uh in
particular the coin margin contracts so
we look at we talked about this last
week the coin margin uh versus the
stable coin margin and why you know why
there's more convexity to the to the
coin margin uh because you know as price
goes down you're not only you know your
p l is decreasing but you're less
collateralized so that's another another
thing to look at is the coin margin open
interest um you can also look at
liquidation levels so i'd like to look
at high block is a really good platform
for that you can see where the
liquidations are so you can say okay if
price goes down to you know x level then
you have a large cascade and so whales
can see this information too right and
so that's why you know you have things
like what happened yesterday where it
basically looked like someone was kind
of stop loss hunting in the sense that
they were trying to trigger a cascade
you know perhaps buy in cheaper or they
went short and then triggered the
cascade right
and so looking at some of these things
can kind of give you some insight into
you know when traders are kind of
getting offsides and when they're in you
know when they're leveraged doing so um
you know that that was a that was like a
pretty you know red flag to me on on
wednesday
but you know we flushed a bit of that
leverage out so so we have another chart
here that's got your tweets overlaid on
it which like to me is i know you're
getting better at this stuff and you're
constantly learning because now you're
starting to time some of this and really
understand how uh the underlying
fundamentals and the on-chain metrics
are uh interfacing with price and on
this graphic what we have is we've got
three tweets of yours the first one says
that the market cap oi uh is rising plus
positive funding then basically you say
hey price is grinding down
and funding is rising fyi kind of giving
a little bit of a warning and then
you've got that by bit funding at a very
high level so maybe walk us through here
you know how accurate is this stuff and
like how do you think about what you're
calling out versus some of the the price
action that we're seeing in more of like
the short term versus the longer term on
chain stuff that i think you know most
people assign uh value to on on chain
yeah totally like in the short term
there's just so much liquidity in the
derivatives market especially the the
perpetual swap market that price is
really driven by it in the in the
shorter term um in in the longer term i
look at on-chain as kind of the oops
it's kind of the the macro right and so
you know when you're trying to look at
what's going to happen over the next
couple days unchain really isn't the
best so we're getting some nice little
price action here uh unchain isn't
necessarily the the best tool for what's
going to happen in the extremely short
term
and so for that like i said you look at
the derivatives data um and so you know
i just threw over not to necessarily
show myself but just to show how the the
concept like remove me from it just look
at the concept itself and and how it's
played out so like on the left you know
you're looking at open interest as a
percentage of market cap rising
meanwhile you had funding increasing as
as price was decreasing same setup after
all-time highs and then once again the
same setup on the right-hand side but on
the right-hand side another thing to
throw in i forgot to mention a second
ago was you can also look at funding
a bit more granularly
you can look at the individual exchanges
so you can look at like you know what's
what's by bit funding doing you know
what what's uh finance finance funding
and then you can go to step further and
say well you know what's by bit coin
margin funding what's by bit usd margin
funding
and so on the right what you'll see is i
was comparing buy bit and binance which
tend to have a lot more retail action
compared to ftx and darabit which this
is a bit of a generalization but it
tends to be a bit more of the the
smarter money uh participates on those
exchanges and so when you see
dislocations between like five bit
binance and darebit and ftx that can be
a little uh a bit of a signal as well
that was that was ironically also
another signal when we called that short
squeeze uh at the end of the summer
same thing in reverse it was that you
had um you had ftx and darabit had
really high funding but by bit and by
and finance actually had really low
funding so it's the complete opposite
setup where you had you know by bit and
binance actually shorting while ftx and
and uh derebit you know they were
longing so it's opposite set up here but
uh it's just another you know you can
get a bit more granular in terms of like
how you're analyzing uh you know where
where the positioning is in the
derivatives market so when we look at
the futures open interest uh you
obviously have like what i would
consider the more uh regulated or
traditional uh places like cme versus
obviously buying by bit finance and the
like uh there's way less leverage in the
legacy system uh than there is on some
of these uh crypto exchanges we've got
this chart that shows just an explosion
of open interest what do you read into
this
yeah i mean this is mostly and due to
the um you know to the the bitcoin
features etf the pro shares etf
and just the demand for the futures
contracts from cme um
and so that you know the reason i the
reason i threw this in is a now cme is
the largest um you know uh futures
exchange which was previously binance
they actually got surpassed by cme this
week
and that's important to understand
because when you're looking at you know
usually we like to look at in the
bitcoin market high open interest is
almost always a you know
a precursor or kind of a a warning
signal to be aware of okay we're
building up a fair amount of um you know
leverage in the system right
um
but you know when you look at with cme
like you mentioned cme doesn't have
nearly the leverage that like finance
offers right um and so i think like you
know on cme you're looking at like 1 to
2x leverage you know at the most versus
on finance you're talking like you know
people getting up to like 20 50 100 x
you know at the very extreme
and so i just think this is important to
kind of keep in account when you're
looking at things like um you know i
look at like market cap you know related
to open interest so the you know how
large open interest is relative to
market cap um to kind of gauge you know
what usually has been a gauge of how
much leverage there's been in the system
but it's just you need to be wary of now
that you know cme is the largest um you
know uh futures exchange that that
that's not necessarily as bearish of a
signal as it has been um it's just
something to keep in mind uh because you
know there isn't that uh as large of a
uh you know amount of amount of leverage
on on cme versus some of these other
exchanges so we talked in the past about
this idea of these same uh contracts
being uh collateralized with bitcoin or
crypto um and the whole idea of the
collateral uh ends up being that we want
as little of it being collateralized by
uh bitcoin right and we actually uh when
it gets higher you get a little nervous
and there's a whole bunch of reasons why
but what we've seen over the last couple
of days or really the last couple of
months is that we continue to go down
but there was like a little bit of a
spike over over the last week or so like
how do you read into this and do you get
worried about these little spikes uh on
this chart here uh you can see at the
end of this like orange line or do you
not worry about kind of the the smaller
moves
right so in in the short term like when
we were talking about a couple minutes
ago about you know how to kind of gauge
leverage in the system one of the things
i mentioned was
looking at the coin margined open
interest so if you look at something if
you look at a platform like uh coinalize
is a great one
you can look at side by side this stable
coin or you know usd margin contracts or
open interest measured against the
actual coin margin and so what this is
doing is this is just looking at what's
the percentage of all of the open
interest that's specifically just coin
margin
and so yeah like
these short term spikes
can can you know be a bit of a red flag
when you pair it with some of the other
things you i'm not gonna rehash the
whole thing but you know what we
mentioned five minutes ago um in terms
of like okay are we like building up a
little dislocation of leverage in the
system maybe we get a flush out right
but
what what i'm really trying to paint a
picture here is just the broader the
broader picture is that
overall we have
way way less uh crypto margins futures
contracts compared to what we did you
know earlier this year
um i suspect as you you know as as
we move past all-time highs you'll start
to see this increase because people are
more bullish on bitcoin and other crypto
assets that they're going to be
margining um these futures contracts
with
but you know we're in a good spot right
now because it's showing you there's
there's less convexity to the downside
right so if we have like a you know a
large liquidation cascade like we did
you know you know
on may 13th
what happened was we had such a large
amount of coin margin contracts that you
know as and and i mentioned this like
two weeks ago i know dylan mentioned it
last week but i i really think it's
important for for people to understand
in terms of like the how this affects
market structure that you know in may
all these people were mark you know they
were collateralized with crypto so as
their p l is decreasing their their you
know margin was decreasing as well and
so it you know creates people
people are more susceptible to being
squeezed you know to the downside so
longs are more susceptible to beginning
squeeze and when you have low percentage
of of contracts that are margin with
crypto aka
a larger percentage that are margin with
stable coins or usd that means that
these these you know
traders on the short side are more
susceptible to getting squeezed to the
upside or short squeezes are
more likely because
when you're collateral when you
collateralize with bitcoin you basically
have this like inadvertent hedge right
so you're you know let's say you're
short bitcoin price starts going up well
your p l is going down because the trade
is going against you know you're betting
prices going down and it's going up but
also your collateral is actually
increasing because bitcoin's price is
increasing so you kind of had this
little hedge right but if you're
collateralized with stable coins then
you don't have that and so it's just
more favorable market conditions for the
balls
when we look at sopra this is i feel
like you and i have been talking about
sober for so long that uh this one's
never going away but we had uh over the
summer uh we were under one which is not
good uh then we went back over one we
bounced off of it a few weeks ago uh
we're trending downward how do you think
about does that mean it goes down to one
is there something else that happens
like if you look at the chart um at the
end of last year we kind of just set
these higher lows um as we moved you
know you know further into the bull run
so i don't necessarily think that we
have to come back down and re-test one
excuse me but if if we do have a
correction like a major correction you
want to see us bounce off one
and so you know just monitor this if you
have a glass node account and i'll you
know throw it in the newsletter next
week or you know tweet about it if
there's anything to be concerned about
but
um you know ideally you would like to
kind of see higher lows right as we kind
of move move higher um but you know if
like the point i'm just trying to get
across is if we do have a correction you
want to see us once again uh bounce off
one as we did uh last month but last
month to me was confirmation that we
were in bullish market structure um
because you're also looking at in this
chart you're looking at the seven day
moving average basically weekly soaper
um
and so this is like the the broader
trend
the daily like you can look at the daily
version i just think it gets a little
noisy in terms of like trying to
identify like okay maybe not what's
going on day to day you can look at the
non you know moving the with it without
the seven day moving average but when
you're trying to understand like you
know what's what's like this broader
market structure i think you can you can
apply that like seven or 14 day moving
average
when we look at the
whales
i'm fascinated by this we have three
lines basically on this next chart one
of them is blue one of them is green and
one looks like it's almost like black or
gray
uh and the blue lines are the smaller uh
holders of bitcoin and it looks like
they just they accumulate no matter what
basically right they're just up and to
the right they're going to continue to
kind of almost dollar cost average it
looks like
but the green line
looks a little bit more wavy if you will
and that is the whales that have more
than 1 000 bitcoin uh in their wallet
they were accumulating aggressively in
september then they started to sell off
the start of october really and then it
looks like they're accumulating again
are they just trading like how do you
think about that activity of they're not
just long only there is some selling
that's going on uh periodically
yeah so first of all like this is
relying on glass node's entity uh
heuristics so it's not perfect right and
so
like
a month or so back you know i would look
at the exact numbers but since then i've
kind of changed my my thinking just
because you know like their heuristics
aren't perfect so you can't rely on like
okay whales have accumulated exactly
this amount of coins um and so i i also
have now started to throw a 14-day
moving average on this to kind of smooth
it out a bit um and so it's i think it's
still useful in the sense that we can
look at what's the trend right but in
terms of getting like the actual like
granular number like raw number i don't
think it's it's fully accurate to look
at in that sense but yeah like generally
what you see is
with with the smaller guys right we're
talking about in the blue line is the
the point one to one btc guys like he
said they accumulate non-stop right you
look at this on like a broader chart
since bitcoin's you know inception it's
just literally like you mentioned you
know up into the right and so you know
if you're gonna like you know present
you're gonna do like some kind of
presentation on you know bitcoin as an
asset to some you know investor like i
would throw that in there right because
you're basically saying like you have
this hardcore um you know group of
people that dollar costs average you
know dollar cost averages into bitcoin
no matter what right they're buying
prices up down whatever they're just you
know they're just taking a passive
amount of their income every you know
day or every week or whatever putting it
into bitcoin
with the whales though um what you see
with with this green line is they
generally uh kind of impact the movement
of the market right because by
definition they're the larger buyers
they generally
sell into strength and buy into weakness
when we look at this sort of in a very
broad sense um and so it's not
surprising to to see them have you know
they initiated a lot of that selling on
the way down moving into the summer
they bought you know some of the
weakness over summer kind of you know
initiated that rally into into july and
they you know they took some profits as
as we you know started to move down a
little bit partially because they were
probably you know moving the market down
a bit because they're large buyers by
definition
but you've started to see them over the
last two weeks accumulating again into
the into this weakness that we've had
since that failed all-time high breakout
and so yeah i mean generally though i
don't i don't look at this on like it on
like a day-to-day basis like i don't
necessarily like say okay whales are
selling like the market's going to go
down um but it it is interesting to see
like you know
people are panicking about like a
shakeout for example like we had
yesterday meanwhile whales have been
buying over the last two weeks into
weakness so
i think to an extent um you could just
you could just look at this to kind of
reassure yourself like okay yeah like
the smart money isn't freaking out like
you shouldn't freak out either
when we look at the supply shock ratios
i think this is where it starts getting
real fun this was part of an epic thread
how long did it take you to put together
like the 22-23 tweet thread
uh i don't know man like like two or
three hours i was just like two or three
you know cups of coffee deep by the end
it was a fantastic thread but when we
look at these supply shock ratios what
is this telling you
sure so oh by the way
you might think this is cool it's it's
in glass node now so i got my like first
metric like officially in glasgow which
is like
really really cool for for anybody else
who likes to like geek out about this
stuff but um but anyway yeah so this is
comparing the highly liquid and liquid
guys it's the illiquid guys so
essentially um the the you know weak to
strong hands oh i'm i'm sorry this is
the this is the long-term holder supply
shower i thought you just pulled up the
other chart we can we can talk about
this one
no the the let's do the long-term holder
supply shock okay yeah sure okay so this
one this is looking at the short term
holder versus long-term holder supply um
and so wait i i've i've actually usually
shown this inverse so people who people
who are confused like oh i've seen this
chart before will why does it look weird
that's why it's it's the opposite of
what it usually looks like
um and so the reasoning is because i
kind of saw this pattern i was staring
at it and i was like hold on like if you
draw trend lines right we're basically
in this kind of descending wedge which
by the way is like a bullish pattern and
technical analysis um but the point i'm
just trying to get across here is that
when we hit the bottom of this trend
line that's usually when we're at the
bottom of these macro corrections so if
you look at you know between the the
2013-2017 bull run you know at the
bottom of the bear market we had two
taps along the bottom of the line um at
you know at the very bottom of the the
2018 bear market and then also during
march we tapped the bottom of the line
and then above the the upper trend line
that's been actually a good signal of
when we've hit these macro peaks so if
you look at 2013 uh 2017 um and so now
you know after we just tagged the bottom
of that um you're so
it's kind of counterintuitive when you
hit the bottom of the line that's
actually when the market uh you know
you're saying that the market is is uh
the most bullish because you have you
have long-term holders that are uh
although this is at the bottom of the
bear market it's saying the long-term
holders have locked up the largest
amount of supply so like the the
expected price appreciation is at the
highest when it hits the bottom of this
trend line essentially
and so we've hit the bottom of the trend
line so in other words what that means
is that long-term holder supply shock
ratio is at an all-time high uh because
the chart's inverse
and you're actually now starting to see
long-term holder supply roll over a
little bit which we've talked about this
many times that's natural uh bull market
behavior right you see long-term holders
accumulate into into weakness in the
bear market they kind of set the floor
lock up a certain portion of supply that
kind of initiates the momentum into the
next rally and then as you know the
reflexivity of a full-blown bitcoin bull
market takes off you know it kind of
becomes a self-feeding thing and then
the long-term holders can then start to
you know sell their bags to the newer
market participants you're now starting
to see the long-term holder supply roll
over a little bit um you started to see
that like right after we had that
all-time high breakout um since then
they like
it's it's kind of flat but
it looks like it looks like it's kind of
topping out which is once again natural
natural you know bull market behavior
from these long-term holders and i
suspect you'll start to see long-term
holder
supply decrease you know more so which
means that we'll move as i put in that
arrow in that in that chart will move
back towards the upper bound of of the
descending wedge so it's
counterintuitive what i'm saying is as
we move higher back towards the upper
trend line it means that long-term
holders are selling their bags to
short-term holders which is natural bull
market behavior that makes complete
sense and and i think it's uh what
you're really highlighting here is
multiple data points are telling us this
exact same thing right which is we're in
a bull market uh there's some short-term
kind of day-to-day stuff uh that is
natural
but that larger macro trend is
definitely still in favor of those that
are holding bitcoin uh the last chart
that we have here is this a entity
adjusted rolling 90-day sum uh of coins
destroyed jesus christ this is a
wonderful yeah long one uh first let's
start with like coin days destroyed i
don't think people understand that
concept and then tell us exactly what
this is uh showing us
sure so for anybody who's like very
visual i know sometimes i like start
rambling all over the place you can i
put on i put a thread out on my twitter
like it's actually in that huge thread
so you can find it in there or if you
want to scroll back a few weeks ago um
but essentially like what destruction
this is a you know it's kind of like a
core concept of on-chain analysis and
something that like anybody who's trying
to get into the space needs to
understand
the you know the the way i would explain
it is if you move a coin to a wallet
right it's let's say we move uh one coin
to a wallet for one day it system that
sits in that wallet for one day it's now
accumulated one coin day
if i then move the coin out of that
wallet after
uh one day then it's now destroyed one
day or if i move the wallet you know if
i move the coin into the wallet for 10
days it's accumulated 10 coin days if i
then move it out of that wallet then
it's now destroyed 10 days
and so that that's kind of the basis of
destruction you can run different ratios
there's other metrics based off of
destruction
but what this is looking at is then so
the the the 90 day thing is just the
rolling 90 day sum so usually we look at
like moving averages right which is the
mean so you look at you know
oh you know over the last 90 days what's
the average right and what this is doing
is this is adding up the previous 90
days so that's where the rolling sum
comes from
um and then you're entity adjusting it
using uh glass nodes you know entity
heuristics
and what you see is that we were and
then on top of this i threw i know this
is like this is like a lot to to like
throw at you but then this is i threw a
90-day moving average on top of the
90-day sum of coin days destroyed uh and
so the point is like the tl dr is that
destruction is at a is is very low um in
a broader sense um you know compared to
to where we've been historically
especially given um you know price
action um usually you see destruction at
uh you know at these lows in the bottom
of the bear market and the reasoning is
because as we talked about that's when
long-term holders are accumulating the
most so that's when you're actually
seeing coin days being created the most
usually you see coin days destroyed at
the top of a bull market and so this is
just another metric showing that you
have really strong hodling behavior um
and so this backs up all the things
we've talked about long-term holder
supply
illiquid supply hodl waves
average spin output life span spent
volume age bands
all these different metrics that are
basically showing you the same thing
that you know you have really strong
huddling behavior this is just another
way to show that it's just showing that
there's very low amount of coin days
being destroyed or very low destruction
meaning that there's there's uh you know
not many old coins being spent
when you kind of zoom out here right
there's all this data and i think that
you and i love looking at this my
brother's like looking at it there's
plenty of other people on the internet
like looking at it
hey i've seen you by the way on twitter
i like your tweets man because it's cool
you're like you're like pushing on chain
and that's awesome i see you like
pumping out stuff about like realize cap
i'm like okay
well here here's what i think ends up
happening right is
as people learn more and more about the
on-chain metrics they start to realize
that uh it's there for everyone to see
and it tells you so much about what's
going on in the network
and if you don't look it's kind of like
if a publicly traded company was to have
a daily um kind of earnings report right
to some degree you could see all this
data but you just say i don't care about
it and so when you start to look at it
you start to one understand uh
the
importance of the unchained data two is
you start to
understand where you are in these like
macro cycles which i think is uh
important uh but also three is it
drastically kind of grounds you from a
psychological standpoint because when
you're just looking and you see oh
bitcoin's up you know right now if you
didn't come on and explain hey the
reason why bitcoin's up right now is
because there's big buyers on coinbase
like all of a sudden you're like okay
there's an action happening and now i
have an explanation right and so i think
as people become more and more familiar
with it i have a crazy thought for you
there's the first time i'm ever saying
this publicly and i'm going to say to
you because i feel like it's fitting
which is historically
understanding accounting was the
language of business
i think that on-chain metrics will be
the language of money moving forward and
so it's you know whoever understands
on-chain metrics you are going to be the
person who really understands money and
understands the flow of capital and
understands what's happening in the
financial markets if you simply just
understand traditional accounting but
you don't understand on chain metrics
you're almost going to be flying blind
in a lot of these capital flows and so i
think that the work that people are
doing in on chain metrics is incredibly
important because one it's not just a
hey let me learn on chain metrics but
also too as you know you've done with
some of the supply shock stuff uh many
others like willy woo or david puel and
dylan and you know all these people
they're coming up with new metrics and
for years to come people will use those
metrics that are being created today as
the standard way to measure various
things and i think that's ultimately
what's kind of so cool about what's
happening right now is just the data's
there it's how do you look at it what
perspective how do you analyze it
and the community continues to kind of
churn out better and better data
analysis uh which then informs millions
of people around the world
no yeah i think i think that's that's
really insightful i you know i've never
thought of it in the sense of like how
you talked about you know accounting the
language of business on change the you
know the language of money i think
that's that's really insightful um yeah
i mean like on chain you know we
essentially just have like x-ray vision
of what's going on with all these market
participants um and and the data is the
truth and like as you said you know you
have you have the data and then you have
the analysis around the data right and
so um you know like when i when i first
started studying this like my analysis
of the data just because i was new to
everything it wasn't great right because
i like first of all didn't have a great
understanding of it um but you know
separating and separating the analysis
from the actual data the data is
indisputable right like we're pulling it
from a blockchain um you know it's
even even people like to talk like okay
what if you're manipulating the data
well if you're manipulating the data
it's just showing what's going on in the
data like
like even if you're i'm still analyzing
what's happening right um and and i
completely agree with you i think of it
as
we're essentially the economists of
bitcoin
right and
the problem is like i've said this
before and then like all the bitcoin the
hardcore bitcoin people were like yeah
well that's a terrible like you know you
don't want to be an economist well it's
like
i mean i
the way i see it is like well economists
haven't had you know indisputable data
from a from a public ledger before right
we have so much granularity basically
are tracking all the transactions that
are going on in every any given day um
you know and
and that's like privacy aside right like
there's like what chain analysis does in
the sense that like they're looking at
who it is i could care less who it is
right i just want to understand what's
the market structure i could care less
about who the individuals are doing
things um
and yeah i mean that's exactly how i see
it that we're basically like the
economist of bitcoin um and as we move
forward this will be more and more
important we'll have new metrics come in
um when you look at the stuff that we
even had earlier this year um you know i
think a lot of you know kind of kind of
the the you know the silver lining from
like on-chain analysis perspective of of
the bear market the mini bear market
over the summer that's what i've been
calling it lately uh is that you know
you had all these new metrics this whole
family of these supply-related metrics
specifically that we now have um that
you know now these are at like the
forefront of my analysis we didn't even
have them before may um and so i can't
even imagine you know in the next year
where we're gonna be it's it's really
cool to see you know people like you um
you know there's all kinds of new
analysts that i see popping up on
twitter that are pushing out new metrics
and it's so it's a very tight-knit
community in the sense that like you
know someone else will put out a metrics
a metric i'll build something on top of
it or dylan will build something on top
of it right and and it's like this
self-feeding uh you know
we're we're open sourcing information
but you know that's the reason why i
really want to push the explanation of
this stuff so hard is that if if i
explain it it might you know hit off a
light bulb with somebody else and they
might run with some metric that i
created right and then they might take a
step further and it just you know we can
all win together in this little niche
thing for now uh i i think you know
at least for now because it's it's so
small in terms of you know where it
where i envision this going uh i think
like on-chain analysis and you know you
know like 10 20 years it's going to be
huge right i think
there's a good chance by the end of the
bull run you'll probably see unchained
metrics on like you know mainstream
media like cnbc and stuff this is the
mainstream media will you are on the
main street nobody watches that stuff
anymore john joe what questions you guys
got you go first johnny um yeah well
what's up congrats you're fired up by
the way i love it um
so can you talk about like when do you
see
this i guess bull market kind of slowing
down um with historical pass and then
when that happens what are you looking
at what metrics are key there
sure so i would say to check out the
thread that i put out um two days ago
it's like my pin tweet i put out 22
different metrics in specific that you
can look at to gauge where we are in the
bull market um all of those would be my
answer uh and i like you know
we could run through them all but i'm
probably gonna have people will sleep by
the end of it but i was looking for some
of those behaviors in the thread um and
also it's kind of like a way i can like
cop out of the answer but you know
scroll through and check out um some of
those things in terms of the behavioral
trends and then also like specific kind
of like price targets um
yeah i mean i i think it's hard to say
though when when the bull market ends um
because a lot of my buddies will come to
me and say um you know when when is the
bull market that's what everybody wants
to know is it going to be december or
january i mean i don't really see it
that way right i look at it more of like
what's
what are the behaviors that we look to
identify when the market is historically
like getting overheated or when is it a
good time to buy um you know when do one
of those behaviors start to look a
little toppy right and so like as far as
like timing-wise it's hard to predict
you know what that would be historically
bitcoin's topped out in december right
but um that that doesn't necessarily go
to say that you know we definitely will
top out in december so i don't really
have a base case
for the timing specifically i just know
like what behaviors i'm going to look
for if that makes sense yeah it does
i'll check out your thread too
appreciate that
joe what do you got uh will so thanks
for all this the anche metrics are
fascinating i think uh not only us but
the the people watching really
appreciate them every week so uh
appreciate that but my question would be
like when we zoom out right uh we've
talked about this before we all and you
specifically have mentioned that we're
gonna be in we're in a bull run right
now right and you're anticipating that
we'll hit uh a hundred thousand in price
whether it's at the end of this year or
shortly thereafter etc are you still uh
sticking to that are you uh feeling
different about it how do the metrics
kind of tell the whole story when you
look at all of them combined
yeah no i think like
if you look at all those metrics in the
thread that i put out um you know the
kind of consensus
is is that we're kind of lukewarm right
in terms of you know how like overheated
if you will we are um we're you know
we're not at you know the bottom of like
a bear market in the sense that like we
have like
insane amounts of room to run but i
think you know i think we still have a
fair amount of
room to go
um
yeah i mean i i don't really have
anything else to say i would i would ask
too like maybe this is way out of left
field and it doesn't have any
correlation but is there any uh kind of
thing that you can draw from we've seen
a bunch of uh of [ __ ] coins frankly
start to get a lot of volume and sort of
get a little market exposure does that
have any impact on the bitcoin market or
none at all
um
the way i see it is like
bitcoin is bitcoin is the you know the
kind of the king in the space and so
when bitcoin moves really aggressively
which i think we haven't really seen a a
real you know move in bitcoin in that
sense since like the end of last year um
you'll start to see the liquidity flow
out of some of these alts right and then
you know i i look at the alt coins from
a trading perspective
as kind of a derivative of bitcoin and
basically like there's a risk curve
right and you know in a bull run you can
go out further on the risk curve and so
this is like something like ralph paul's
talked about and like i know all the
bitcoiners give him so much [ __ ] about
like owning all coins but
he's a traitor right and so what what
he's what he's saying in terms of like i
remember he came on on your guy's show
and he was like i'm really heavyweight
east
the reasoning is because he knows that
we're in the the second half of a bull
run and the further you
you know the further towards the peak of
the bull run you go the further out on
the risk curve you can go in terms of
you know the assets that you hold and so
yeah i mean i suspect that a lot of
these all coins are probably gonna run
right and and you'll see these these
really large moves in in some of these
names like solana ethereum etc um you
know i don't own those things i own
bitcoin um but you know that's not to
say that you won't see you know usd
appreciation and those things and
they're they're way more reflexive than
bitcoin which
just means like in the bull run they're
gonna they're probably gonna outperform
bitcoin right and then but in the bear
market they're gonna dramatically
underperform bitcoin um and so i mean i
think you just if you're gonna mess
around with that stuff like you need to
understand you know risk and and
understand like how these things uh
behave with each other um because at the
end of the day these things are really
just kind of orbiting around bitcoin um
you know if if bitcoin bitcoin
absolutely nukes well the market's going
to nuke i mean maybe you have like one
or two coins that are like decorated
from the rest of the market but
generally speaking you know bitcoin has
a large move um you know the way to
think about it is like
all coins being long all coins are
basically it's basically being short
bitcoin volatility right and so if
bitcoin is volatile in either way then
you probably don't want to be long all
coins at least in the short term gotcha
well when you think about uh all of
these on-chain metrics when you wake up
in the morning what do you check first
like what's the very first thing that
you're like that's what i run to that
because that tells me you know as much
as i need uh as the first thing
sure it's it's obviously price right um
and then second of all it's it's the
derivatives data um because i check like
the on-chain data at least on glass node
um updates at 8 30 p.m
um so like i mean i'm on my computer
like 8 25 like give me the data right
and as soon as it loads i like i get my
fix right i figure out everything that
happened for the day and that's it right
like the data really doesn't fluctuate
that much from an enchanting perspective
like day to day um but yeah like the the
derivatives data changes all the time
right like you're about like funding
open interests uh you know looking at
like the cbd to gauge like spot like
just some of these different things you
know the order books i watch those
throughout the day
i would say some of those things like
definitely the the first two things that
i chuck in the morning are what's you
know price um you know were there
liquidations if there's if there's a
large move um and then also like you
know what is what is what is funding and
um you know also like on open interest i
look at you know like we mentioned the
coin versus stable coin thing like a bit
of granularity but in general um the the
derivatives data because that that like
we mentioned that stuff really drives
you know the short term price
yeah it's fascinating to me that's what
you run to first it says so much about
like the importance of that data set so
i appreciate it all right
next friday halloween stories bring one
or two good ones pg versions but bring
them
well a bus burned last year supposedly
what are you guys getting into
what john what are you doing for
halloween um i don't really have plans i
think i am uh
busy all weekend
i so i was gonna get some laughs yeah
okay
johnny's got his costume picked out
already he's ready to go joe's dog has a
costume yeah what's wrong with you well
wait are you dressing up for halloween
nah bro
i'm probably just gonna like throw a
basketball jersey on or something like
half-ass it well they were asking in the
chat if you're gonna dress up like a
wizard
[Laughter]
you know maybe i'll come on here there
we go
will that's joe's dog dressed like a
taco i mean i don't know if i would say
is that a golden retriever yeah
you like it sick yeah yeah i love golden
steel yeah well
that's why i got one will
will this one is a good dog but it owes
me money so it's a whole other topic
don't worry about it uh-oh dog owes me
money though all right appreciate you
man uh twitter where can uh where can we
send people
sure uh w clementi three um and then
newsletters newsletters in the bio
you know maybe maybe next week i'll come
on in a wizard costume
you can only do that if we're above like
seventy thousand dollars you can't come
on on a date that we're down and price
it with a wizard costume because it
doesn't work but if we're up then uh
then you can do whatever you want
he knows volatility
awesome man all right thank you so much
for uh for taking the time to do this
we'll see you on friday
all right you guys have a good weekend
later well thanks move bye guys